Oh, my goodness.
This dude Brian Nicholera
I went to high school with
just friended me,
he just moved here.
Oh, my God.
People from high school
only friend you, like,
after business hours
if they wanna hook up.
Really? I had a huge
crush on him.
Oh, you should
ask him out.
I can't just do that.
Oh, my God,
he "likes" "Roseanne."
Okay, this is--
This is your new
sexual partner.
All right,
I'm asking him out.
I'm just gonna do it.
Do it.
This is so great.
Like, why are we waiting for
guys to come to us, Ilana?
Did Amelia Earhart
wait to be
asked to fly
around the world?
Definitely not.
She asked.
And then they
said no.
But she still did it.
And she died, but she,
like, died doing it.
(Abbi)
Exactly.
I'm doing it again,
I'm asking someone else out.
This is the Abbi I love
and fell in love with
and I'm obsessed with.
Skylar Cummings-
Conkelmann,
I used to babysit
for him.
He was adorable.
He's...
Yeah, he's 20,
that's acceptable.
Troy Megliarino.
He spent a hot sec in jail,
but he lives in South Jersey
and I know he'd steal a car
and come up for the night.
Chris Wazcyleski,
he was a nude model
in my life drawing
class and he, like,
always angled
himself out to me.
Chad Michael Fong.
We met at a hardware store,
he was disgusting.
You know, I'm picking all
white dudes right now.
I must be craving
pink dick.
I'm gonna
go with this.
(Abbi)
Okay, who else,
who else?
Henry Rowdenbush, had a unibrow
all through middle school
and then he started waxing it
and all of a sudden it was like,
glasses off, you're
(bleep) gorgeous.
It's like
"She's All That."
I feel like I'm on
coke right now.
P.J. Mallory.
Bobby Cornhauser.
Johnny Fissinger.
Danny McCarrow.
Ryan Long.
Rod White.
We are, like, feminist
heroes right now.
So, okay,
that's 36 guys
that we've been rejected
by and one lady.
Okay, so what, dude?
You know what?
The Internet
is so '90s.
Let's go find
some guys IRL.
You know, you can just
say "in real life."
It's the same number
of syllables.